Chili Con unity wall plate preparation
el correo postal union all recruit
window decoration again livello global
migration Consiglio della Commissione
separazione
President President Europe members bis
videos films in Brussels weather
December European Council will discuss
the ongoing covid-19 crisis in recent
developments in Belarus and you cry
little  fellow of the touch of energy
prices security and defense the external
dimension of migration and other foreign
policy ich is the serious
epidemiological situation die Serbia
Council Villas only one day it will take
place tomorrow
birthday and it will be presented by the
eastern partnership Summit will take
place today and will be followed by your
awesome it still on Thursday
Council meeting with start with the
usual exchange with President Sasori
first let me focus on the recent
resurgence of the covid-19 pandemic
working session in which they will
discuss the ongoing fight against the
covid-19 pandemic in respons  e to rising
numbers and the emergence of new variant
Omicron Member States the pipe major
santinho the nation remeis further to
ensure that new restrictions are
targeted and proportionate do not
underline the functioning of the single
market not
necessarily Camper three movements
in fighting with pandemic adults
including  Booster shot
fafsa to be successful Winnetou overcome
vaccine hesitancy and fight this
information
List grow globally sharing Erfurt
whether he plays a major role having
United one hundred million vaccine dose
to six countries of the EU and its
Member States with paper bags and
sharing drukowac send my  little the
nation biker meeting to read seven
hundred million dose at mit 2000 ready
to have something made to help develop
local manufacturing capacity
as that we need to be prepared for
future Kreises lyrics back to discuss
crisis management and the silence on the
basis of the Council conclusions  agreed
in the member on the subject  of members
learning to the subject of tomorrow's
meeting
on the European Council of
hanwell
energy prices for the publication of the
expected to invite
Gentoo Förder examine the functioning of
electricity market and trading on the EU
ETS market and to follow-up
appropriately
Lederhose expected to go  for the swift
examination of the proposal to revise
the third energy package the walking
dead will discuss about the fundamentals
situation in Belarus as well as the
humanitarian crisis and its borders by
the bell Russian regimes ongoing
instrumentalists of immigration
devolucao exchange views on the walking
security strategy  Grace Potter and see
how to react to death in the afternoon
working session Liedes will assess the
implementation of the June and October
European Council conclusions on the
external dimension of migration reasoned
action plans for countries of origin and
transit to be made operational and
implemented without further  delay in
cooperation w  ith partner countries and
adequate financing must be mobilized for
migration related action on all routes
in the area of ​​security and defense
leaders are expected to give guidance on
the strategic compass and call for
strength and strategic partnership with
native to new joint declaration
expected to come back  to security and
defense again in March 2000 ready to one
day we Lindos the strategy Compass
relations between the European Union and
the African Union Aaron the gender as
leaders will discuss the preparation for
the
African Union
something for the very next Tuesday
in the
will be joined  by President of the ECB
end Eurogroup for Europe summit in
inclusive
people
grazie
Prime Minister
that is of course
primarily due to the pandemic these
mixed feelings and I think like
many of you it makes me sad
that we are again
overshadowed by the pandemic this Christmas  see but
on the other hand I'm also full  he
confidence because we now have the
strength and, above all, the
means
to put an end to this pandemic in the long term and to
overcome it we have worked very
hard this year to make these
funds available and above
all  to build better and new structures
and to face the pandemic
what is the situation today we are facing
a double challenge
on the one hand we see that the covid-19
cases
have increased rapidly in Europe there
are some member states that are
recording the highest new infection
rates they have ever had
and of course also associated with this an
increasing number of cases of illness
a growing burden on
hospitals and a Wii lament an
increase in deaths
one should not forget or
it is always very important to
consider that this high increase in
new infections is almost exclusively due to
the Delta variant  is
and what mic  h is concerned that we are
now additionally seeing on the horizon omega
the new variant which is obviously
still contagious if you look at the
time of doubling the cases of
new infections it is
just two to three days this is rapid
and we know science is telling us
that  we have to reckon with the fact that by mid-
January Omikron will already be the new
dominant variant in Europe
, but we have worked hard in the
past year and we have achieved a
lot, so today Europe is
better prepared to fight this virus
and for two main
reasons, firstly, we have  had enough
vaccine for every European every
European this year namely
a total of more than 1 billion vaccine doses
then today more than 66% of the
European population are doubly vaccinated i.e.
fully vaccinated that is more
than 300 million people and
additionally 62 million people have now received
the booster vaccination and
we know  nd that science and
says that the first data with Omicron
shows that this triple vaccine is the
best
protection against Omicron available in the world today, of
course we still have to research a lot more
about Omicron, but thanks to the
work of our health authority Hera
, we now have a wide network of
Science and laboratories, with which we
gain new insights every day regarding
the new variant and, above all,
the danger it poses.
Secondly, our starting position is also
better because we are now able
to produce 300 million vaccine doses here in Europe every month  we
now have resilient
supply chains, we have contracts
that ensure we also get
Diana vaccines adapted to new variants
immediately and
looking at Omicron now, the companies
say they
need about 100 days to adapt the vaccine
and we are working closely with the
European  with  Medicines Agency EMA
together that parallel to the development
of the Omicron adapted vaccine,
so to speak, the approval process is running
because the adapted vaccine can
then also be approved as quickly as
possible,
which means we remain vigilant, we
have planned carefully and both
are now paying off, the
most important thing is the
vaccination quotas in  To bring Europe up as quickly as
possible, including
children of all ages
,
and to do this
we need to get closer to people, we need to make
more appointments for vaccinations,
we need to create more spontaneous
vaccination opportunities and,
in particular, we need to help in the
Member States  which
are still lagging behind
in some Member States in terms of vaccination stamps, the
Commission has now also started
to launch targeted campaigns on social media
simply to improve
information in those Member States
who improve the
effects  amability of the vaccines means that we
will also make every effort from our side
to help overcome the vaccine skepticism
because, ladies and gentlemen,
the price we are all
paying meanwhile leads to low vaccination quotas is becoming higher and higher the numbers
the people are paying the society
Our health system pays this
price time our economy,
but this also applies to the many older
fellow citizens who will
not be able to see their granddaughters again this Christmas. This applies above
all to the children who
cannot go to school again, my God
what is  that for life and friend's time
learning time that we take away from you
that means they all make sense who is
guilty that I have everyone vaccinated and
that would fight this pandemic with all my might
moreover Europe has delivered
to the rest of the world on an unprecedented scale in terms of substance
if you look at
the numbers globally
then 44% of the world's population will now be
fully vaccinated and Europe has
an outstanding share of this we have delivered more
than 1.4 billion vaccine doses to 150
countries
and
we are now also the world's largest
vaccine donor
we have passed on
377 million vaccine doses from
Europe to date and  Although mainly at
korvax
and in this are also 50 million
vaccine doses that we have given bilaterally
to the countries of the Western
Balkans and the Eastern Partnership
, billions of people around
the world have not even received their
first vaccination and the continent
that needs our support the most
is  Africa there are just 7% of the
population vaccinated, for this
reason we are working flat out on a
package for Africa, also with a view to the
EU-Africa summit that we will
have in the near future, we not only want to make
more vaccines available
but and  this is often one
more obstacle  work on the
infrastructure work more on
medical training
provide more syringes provide more
infrastructure that
is necessary for vaccination options
all medical equipment all of this
must be intensified,
we as Team Europe are also working
on this with our partners in Senegal,
Rwanda and South Africa and together with
to enable the private sector to build up RNA production capacities yes
ladies and gentlemen this
pandemic is unprecedented in our
history but our answer is that
too
online members
besides the pandemic we will also
discuss at the European Council Adam and
issues from energy prices and the
overall economic situation
indeed to the mission Regimes hybrids
attack against a Member States Lithuania
Poland and Latvia
autocratic Regimes
attempt to disable eyes all Member
States has completely failed
Nico sauer Union reacted robaszkiewicz
great solidarity and unity
humanitar  ian assistance
with
tailored subset of sanctions
supported voluntary returns and the
results within Just Dance now more than
three thousand five hundred my friends
have been returned safely from Belarus
to Iraq
ladies and gentlemen this situation
with Belarus should be in the know why
the context menu
disable  the security of the Seas
we all have seen the report of Russia's
messebilder of military the long Yu
Krems eastern border and although the
attempt to the stable as you train from
within
i want to throw away the ring commitment
to you Grant serenity and territorial
integrity as  well as the right of any
sovereign state to determine its own
future
will see the blade and attempt to
intimidate moldoras reformist ever meant
by squeezing them on gas supplies the
time of high energy prices and we must
protect from society and our timocracy
from this kind of  sinical giropay
of course we want good relations with
Russia but whether this is possible
depends first  and foremost on Russia's
behavior
the Time Rush s.to Single breath of
posture visavis neighbors and the
European Union and partners have very
clear
Förderkreis effects against you crane
will have massive costs for Russia
in June the European Council esta stars
to come up with options
and  since then we have been working on
this in close cooperation
with the United States and other
partners we are prepared
method of economic sanctions inplace
target in the financial and energy
sector
dual-use goods and defense
response to any further question may
take the form of the  robust scaling up
and expansion of Music System sanctions
and of course we are ready to take the
snow an President that matches with
serious consequences for Russia
Paderborn
iCal on Russia to the Escalade
diplomatic channels on tour by by its
international commitment conflicts must
be solved peacefully
Metamizol  EDP
the
promise
Ella Jones Facebook but covid-19 or
coordination
durable in  Mering
C profile
only servo travel chickens e-move motors
merci
social so at merci beaucoup
oxazepam awaken family
merry christmas merry christmas
[applause]